ladies and gentlemen I have the
declaration a result of Paul Theru
slippery Council the election of a
member of parliament for the road clear
parliamentary constituency on Thursday
the 8th - June 2017 I Allan Grahame
being the acting returning officer that
a rush cliff constituency do hereby give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each candidate is as follows
Clarke Kenneth Harry the Conservative
Party candidate thirty thousand two
hundred and twenty three faithful
Matthew Eric you kit 1490 Melinda George
Richard the Green Party 1626 melon David
Labour Party twenty two thousand two
hundred and thirteen Phoenix Jane
Liberal Democrat 2759 there one 157
sport papers - for want of an official
mark 49 for voting for more candidates
and the voters entitled 106 B no mark 4
holy Boyd an uncertainty the vacant
seats the electorate was 75 4738 ballot
papers issued fifty eight thousand four
hundred and seventy-seven turnout
seventy eight point two four percent and
i do hereby declare that kenneth Harry
Clark is duly elected as Member of
Parliament for the Russell if
constituency
well ladies and gentlemen can I first
give my grateful thanks the electors of
Rostov I have been elected a few times
before but I always regard it as a
privilege to be asked again to represent
the constituents with whom I seek to
identify very closely I feel that they
are the kind of people that I'm familiar
with and I will do my best to represent
them to the best of my ability I thank
the returning officer and all those
people who've helped with the
organization of today and with the count
I have occasionally made flippant
remarks about the late conclusion of the
rustle account on some occasions I have
improved totally wrong on this occasion
and the whole thing has been conducted
extremely smoothly it's always conducted
smoothly and efficiently but it's also
been done with remarkable speed so we at
least to this part of the election
results is concluding it a perfectly
reasonably civilized hour of the morning
but anyway congratulations and thanks to
all those who have taken part
congratulations - thanks to my opponents
we always have a civilized election in
the Russian if consistency I think this
one was it's the strangest one ever
thought because the Prime Minister vey
inconveniently from my point of view
decide to hold this election when I was
having to have medical treatments and
hadn't operations I have never
campaigned less in all my life but I
managed to campaign a bit and win my
encounters with my opponents political
opponents it was as usual very civilized
very fair very congenial and I
congratulate them on the campaign they
ran on behalf of their respective
political parties I will resist the
temptation at this time morning to start
indulging my own version of pundit Rhee
on what is turning out to be one of the
most remarkable at general elections and
I can remember for a very long time with
the National result still in doubt huge
regional variations I think we are in
the middle of
great events the whole structure of
politics has been changing in the last
two or three years the old confident
predictions you could make a few years
ago can no longer confidently be made
and we're still waiting to see what kind
of Parliament we'll have tomorrow this
Parliament will have to address some
very great and historic matters because
it isn't just brexit a lot of very big
problems going to faces in the next five
years our conclusions I began it will
therefore be a particular privilege to
be able to take part in the political
debates and discussions there and I will
certainly try to make sure that the
opinions of all the inhabitants of
Russia live are properly and effectively
represented in the time that I will
serve thank you all very much
[Applause]